bonus est lui aussi venu récupérer money
and youth and me in the mirror
et
ça dépend de quelques jours dans le mois
si j'ai mon rêve il
je fais la gueule a peur
si je sens bien moi je suis très flou
dans le matin moi je regarde pas tout de
suite dans la glace je réside on lire
dimanche dans l'iss du fruit des choses
comme ça je me laisse tous les sens
indre blood et bien ma tête doucement
après j'étais un peu d'air sur cinq vit
comme ça et quand je regarde finalement
que j'ai fait comme ça sans savoir
devant ces pratiques
would you paint ball et vivre à des
traducteurs dont un physique allemand je
change
changerait mes jambes rentrer les genoux
et les chevilles
ils sont trop petits
chalets d'être cheval des gens de chez
vale do you think you are 10 and driving
aux looks ecosia de bradford swing ouais
oui on est tous moi heureusement je
trouvais ça dans moins de l'homme et la
femme il faut maintenant je trouvais
bien nous menons le femme elle va venir
ça commence
j'attendrai d'être dans le lendemain du
violent
ayew bassiste c'est pas vrai il y avait
quand même cru stanick et des noirs bon
et ça veut dire et il est noir même il a
les yeux bleus là les yeux verts mais il
est noyé jamais et cannes justement
parce que je pense
moi je suis
dans ma tête j'ai envie européenne c'est
sûr ça et être dans notre vie avant je
ne sais pas j'ai appris le français dans
trois mois j'ai pris l'état liens dans
deux semaines ça veut dire c'est pas
normal j'ai cru les français je lis
j'écris et je n'ai jamais bien pour ça
alors
j'ai envoyé un avis réoriente ses
satires maudit du loose when you left
jean paul goude j'ai rien perdu parce
que
j'ai beaucoup à apprendre
j'étais en pleurs immature ça veut dire
j petite fille
une occupe vraiment beaucoup finalement
à la fin j'ai juste il même dans un
autre façon qui lui tout pas m'aimer et
lui il voudrait que moi je laime dans sa
façon de manger paypal ébloui un délit
finalement je pense on est tous les deux
trente grandes ligues ou à des grandes
grandes et il est venu à doute et
maintenant on est vraiment des amis
on
je comprends maintenant
je laime lui maintenant les façons je
voudrais été mais au contraire alors
restés amis l'amour est cent des plus
grands viavant sauf en vie at les gens
sentent sinon
ça car
on est trop fort pour rester tous les
jours ensemble
86 ans on lui a dit jean paul goude in
school in faris du même
nom je vois tout le temps
je mène avec noir bon moi qu'avant parce
que il est en école est quand même j'ai
les joies peut-être plus que quelqu'un
qui
qui reste dans la maison où tous les
jours avec nous et
pour moi le temps que je lui donne c'est
un temps de qualité et
quand je fais le tour n'est tout ça en
lui les par l'école il est avec moi
quand et moi j'ai quand même difficile
l'école ans et moi j'ai pour les
comprendre heureusement il ya ça prouve
qu'on a c'est super parce que je prends
du temps
ces trois événements
c'est ce traître ni grève ni
oui ni non
lui rigole maintenant il 10
bon dans ma famille on a puisé du fol
alors ça va les habitués c'est pour ça
il est prête à pasteur parce que sinon
lui même et qui te fait des bêtises
comme ça
passe ça veut dire je peux pas parler
justement de ca
c j'ai encore le
justice est donc toujours alors après le
14 décembre je peux venir encore et je
peux tout dire pourquoi bon il ya des
gens de famille de christ amis et tout
ça qui était là dedans et c'est qu'ils
sont dangereux de nourriture
oh
oh moi
j'arrête j'ai arrêté de la main parce
que c'est pas à cause de ça marche pas
parce que chaque fois je fais un truc
c'était trop long là
faire ça veut dire de cinéma pour jouer
un rôle premières rôles en même un
douzième roland troisième rôle ça veut
dire ça prendre sept mois des tavillons
new album holly plus forte pour le voir
c'était moi
j'écris ces paroles c'était la fin d'un
relations
privées on a fait un très grand gaillard
j'étais tellement fâché alors ces
chansons pour moi c'était un excellent
6e ça veut dire girveau nous tous là
jean marc barr de music ces crises thani
qui a fait la mise et que c'est un
écrivain compositeur jamaïcaine qui
gérait contre là bas on attendait un
heureux ont commencé travailler ensemble
j'ai joué il explique tout les choses
qui m'arrivent avec mon ancien amour et
tout ça alors la tamise et très très dur
coup de grisou wild bill hickok
battre
tout il ya tout d
essayer d un girl a dedans et que tu te
fâche
sortie s'est libéré finalement yoann own
the night clubbing personnes
normalement je voudrais appeler ce
dividende sera sauf ça veut dire
vraiment dans ce qu'est ce qu'être
unique
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou